bello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj e come
sempre siamo in un nuovo video e dal
giorno 1 ma quando ho iniziato a fare lo
youtuber che tutti mi fate la stessa
domanda sei fidanzato no perché io sono
disponibile anche quella ma non è questa
la domanda di oggi oggi rispondo alla
domanda incredibile quali sono i miei
youtuber preferiti che me lo chiedete
sempre da sempre me lo chiedono tutti
oggi disponiamo questa domanda lui
diventeranno youtube
io ci farò la top5 youtube che
preferisco nel mondo è in generale
quindi non in italia anche perché di
youtuber italiani ne seguo veramente
pochi forse quasi nessuno guardiamo
dalla posizione number five di questa
top 5 si è signore la posizione numero 5
troviamo per chi silver phag rainet
perfect per me sono gli youtubers per
eccellenza cosa vuol dire vuol dire che
loro hanno un canale di youtube
esattamente come youtube vorrebbe che
fossero i canali youtube i loro
contenuti sono 100 per cento originali e
fanno dei video ragazzi parte che chan
50 milioni di iscritti c'è la qualità
dei loro video e devastante allora
allora io li metterei quasi principali
mete di mettere i primi semplicemente il
fatto che questa è una mia top five
solo che hanno una qualità di contenuti
che nessuno può raggiungerci hai bisogno
di una troupe pazzesca per questa roba
veramente fanno tutti pazze schifani
trichet prete lanciano delle cose da
lontano fanno centro nelle come per gli
spieghi perfette fanno cose stranissime
comunque li avete visti sicuramente alla
posizione numero 4 ragazzi troviamo
l'inimitabile set
ever ma chi è costui chi è quest'uomo
diversamente dotato di capelli proprio
come me siamo due persone completamente
opposte io e lui appunto pare tranne le
sopracciglia le sopracciglia sono uguali
7 vernay ragazzi e noi hutu perché non
saprei neanche descrivere bene che cosa
fa fa video come lo spiego che fa queste
cose
[Musica]
non l'ha fatto anche la cover di bb
cover di billy haley comunque un signore
youtube c'è allora in realtà non sono
anche se definirlo youtuber perché
proprio una persona un uomo del web
veramente incredibile c'è il motivo
paragonano a dio e sono d'accordo
mi dispiace non poter parlare di più di
lui perché farlo è talmente
psichedeliche che non saprei come
descriverlo è proprio diciamo che da
quando ho iniziato a seguirlo circa da
un quasi un annetto ogni video che ha
fame perché sono fortissimi ma ogni
video che ha fatto me lo sono visto ben
mi ricordo tutti ed è forse l'unico
youtube di quei guarda tutti i video per
adesso merita tantissimo poi vabbè
comunque saputo lasciare tanto noi
sicuramente siamo alla posizione numero
3 posizione e naba flipper
lo so che gli fa strano la faccenda è
che le cose stanno veramente così allo
ragazzi molti di voi non c'è bisogno che
vi faccio vedere quel fa marco merlino
immagino lo sappiate motivo mi ha sempre
chiesto ma dov'è nata per stato amicizia
nei confronti di marco è nata per chi lo
seguiva e l'ho detto all'inizio del
video che non seguo youtube italia
tranne proprio 2 ott resto non ci sta
neanche in una top five è uno di questi
due o tre che seguo e marco altri sono
tipo scottex io topi il gatto su un tubo
però lui marco secondo me quest'anno
cosa che forse molti non riescono a
capire perché magari non seguono youtube
tempo ma marco a parte il fatto che
prima ancora che iniziasse a fare il
video su questo canale io già lo seguivo
perché marco faceva già video prima e ha
sempre avuto una comicità nei video che
scritta apposta ho scritto apposta per
la mia persona questo vuol dire che a me
persona a me lorenzo studi piace quello
che marco fa magari voi se guardate
marcon non necessariamente mi fa ridere
ma messi è tanto anche con il fatto e
marco ha una qualità a livello di idee a
livello di creatività che in pochi forse
nessuno anzi nessuno mi sento di dire
nessuno in italia ha per lui un secondo
fa succedere di tutto nei suoi video c'è
un video ha deciso che di marco ci mette
settimane a montarlo solito incredibili
cioè se voi non avete mai guardato
seriamente marco marino fatevelo dire da
una persona che comunque fa video da un
sacco di tempo marco merlino e uno delle
youtuber al mondo che di più si sbatte
per il singolo contenuto a livello di
idea livello di montaggio
marco è quasi insuperabile io non l'ho
messo perché marco italiano e non l'ho
messo perché è mio amico l'ho messo
perché davvero credo a questa cosa e io
quando ho conosciuto mario sono stato
proprio contento di conoscere una
persona per capire che cosa si cela
dietro a un pazzo maniaco del genere ed
è la risposta è stata che lui dal vivo è
pazzo maniaco per 2 rispetto a quello
che vedete voi luce lui nei video si
contiene marco è incredibile secondo me
merita la terza posizione dei miei topi
youtuber mondiali e non sto scherzando
ma da anni signore signori se siete
esperti di videogiochi sicuramente
conoscerete questo canale che sto per
nominare al secondo posto tra i miei
youtuber preferiti al mondo troviamo
jason fermo
la canzone si fugge un un asino detto
sarmi da questa parte
lui ma gli ming e è vero spiego io il
natale non so come si chiami lui come
persona non ho idea visto che lui non fa
neanche vedere la sua faccia nei video
da un canale di gaming prende un
videogioco totalmente da zero e fa una
specie di backstop tipo i miei momenti
epici di cose che gli sono successe che
fanno strani dere durante il gioco che
succedono durante il gioco non fa solo
quello ma principalmente fa quello di
bobby preferite quello di zen dove vi ha
giocato zelda ti pongono sono 50 ore di
queste 50 ore ci ha fatto cinque minuti
di video dove in questi cinque minuti
succede di tutto ma di tutto anche metal
gear ha fatto la stessa cosa in sa
quello che ha fatto la stessa cosa video
che in banchi se non lo conoscete
ragazzi se masticate anche solo un po di
inglese ma anche solo masticate
l'inglese chissenefrega tanto quello che
fa vede anche solo senza capire niente è
bellissimo
molti di voi e io ho già ve lo dico
molti di voi si aspettano che adesso in
mente più di bike no per un motivo allo
ragazzi io che di buy
non lo seguo più da anni ok perché più
di pai
a me piaceva quando faceva videogiochi
poi io sono cresciuto insomma sono
cambiate anche un pò i miei gusti
eccetera il pd poi ha cambiato il suo
form adesso farm in review fa tante
altre cose insomma che noi che sono
divertenti mi piacciono però non come
prima perché avevi pd by piaceva il mood
che aveva nel fare i video ma quando io
ero più piccolo quindi poi ha segnato la
mia adolescenza
la prima posizione dello youtube perché
preferisco di avviso già molti di voi
anzi nessuno lo conoscerà il signore e
signori stavo rompendo il green screen
davy five four davi e 504 in italiano e
uno youtuber che fa video sul basso
e voi dite dovrei ma che te che cazzo te
ne frega del basso no e allora ma niente
in realtà del basso per quanto io simile
perché io steel un sacco le persone che
sanno suonare uno strumento a
prescindere perché io ho vissuto il mio
papà che musicista so quanto sia
difficile suonare uno strumento e so
quanto è difficile suonarlo bene qui si
tra di voi ci sono persone che sono uno
strumento avete la mia stima
io ho iniziato a suonare la chitarra
quando ero più piccolo dovrebbe iniziare
in realtà è lui non sarebbe d'accordo
per niente perché se lo leggo ho
iniziato ad apprezzare di molto di più
il basso da quando ho iniziato magari
sui video perché mi ha fatto proprio
innamorare quasi di questo strumento
perché dal nulla ha tirato fuori dei
contenuti incredibili disse sono
contenuti musicali
ok ma non necessariamente cioè non è che
suona e basta lui fa proprio dei
montaggi divertenti diventa dire
qualsiasi cosa c'è mai in giro sono alle
canzoni dei meme alla gente la gente li
deve indovinare oppure è andata in
africa per suonare africa dei toto o
guardando il suo canale oggi è come se
guardassi di di vaio a 16 anni cioè mi
dà le stesse veramente sensazioni
positive e mi diverte tantissimo e non
mi perdo un video ei suoi video sono
anche lunghi dai 10 ai 20 minuti più o
meno anche cordi ce n'erano però più o
meno fa video abbastanza lunghi e mi
riguardo tutti all'inizio alla fine
anche se non mastica temi in vere e
provate a guardare uno dei suoi video
perché meritano tantissimo veramente
tantissimo secondo me è attualmente uno
dei youtuber al mondo che merita di più
e personalmente e il mio attuale non vi
ho detto una cosa è italiano però di
avervi divertito e spero so che molti di
questi probabilmente anzi forse quasi
tutti tranne marco non li conosceva te
meglio se non conosciate su youtube è
meglio perché oggi vi ho fatto scoprire
della qualità e non sto scherzando sono
convinto di questa cosa ma adesso
facciamo una roba jean pierre b da
adesso lo chiamo vi faccio vedere la mia
top five
voglio vedere le sue reaction a ogni
persona che sto per far vedere sono
veramente curioso
allora io ho fatto vedere la mia top
five vai alle persone quindi oggi ti
faccio vedere partendo dalla quinta
posizione andamento anche chi sono i
miei 5 allora tu hai una cosa di
haisentito non ho sentito nulla che ho
visto niente perfect ok
conoscendoti però soprattutto dopo gli
ultimi tablet e messaggi inter o nome
c'è il tizio verso nel basso ok partiamo
dalla posizione numero cinque del etico
perché preferisco questo è il numero 5
[Musica]
allora ticamente subito anche loro se
come sono gli youtuber che preferisco a
livello proprio di come fanno video
secondo me sono gli youtuber per
eccellenza ma hai detto anche che molti
sui loro video sono fake oppure permette
assolutamente assurdo grande che non ho
assolutamente edibile alla posizione
numero 3 chi ti aspetti come youtube
enrique top per me perché io non lo
abbia messo anche per avere la top 3
pare che permetta questione
la squadra deve montare anche per me
posizione numero 2 dopo non sia più io
lo conosco però non lo siamo da un nono
ti piace e non poi così tanto ok
posizione numero 1 beh secondo me è il
suo momento di 80 si doveva mettere
allora dài
allora mi fa sorridere ovvero e poi è
veramente forte e ha una comicità un po
di youtube old style che continua
comunque rinnovarsi stilisticamente e va
bene anche pesare tutto il bravo e chi
ci sta comunque questa la top five sono
contento che sia stato abbastanza
d'accordo niente finisce qua non doppi
del lavoro a quest'uomo se no continua
montesso video all'infinito ast un
bacino uccidiamo percepito lasciate mi
piace siete dei canali sia chat e la
campanellina perché è importante che
sono le notifiche e
[Musica]